blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to
blinkist.com pakman all right welcome
everybody let's jump right in uh we
haven't done a good old-fashioned a
press briefing wacky questions segment
in a little bit i checked in on the
press briefing that took place on
wednesday this week and some really
pretty wacky stuff is going on uh first
of all fox news's peter ducey is still
trying to ask these gotchas of jensaki
she's actually increasingly well
prepared to handle them and here is one
where
after some comments joe biden made
peter ducey
is asking whether
if a parent doesn't like their kids
curriculum
they should be considered a domestic
terrorist extremely misleading i'll
explain in a moment does the
administration agree that parents upset
about their kids curriculums could be
considered domestic terrorists well let
me unravel this a little bit because the
national school board association is not
a part of the us government i'd point
you to them what the department of
justice said in a letter from the
attorney general is that quote threats
against public servants are not only
illegal they run counter to our nation's
core values that is true these were
threats against public servants threats
against uh members of the school board
regardless of the reasoning uh threats
and violence against public servants is
illegal now you might be wondering
what on earth is peter ducey talking
about and what he's talking about is the
mobilization of the federal government
to some degree
on the basis of escalated threats
against educators and the insanity
that's happening at the school board
meetings the problem is not taking
seriously
the behavior of parents at school board
meetings uh that that's what we should
be doing the problem is that
the school board meetings are getting
completely insane and what this entire
thing is in reference to
um is that
last week the national school boards
association pressed biden for federal
assistance to review whether violence
and threats against public school
officials
could be considered a form of domestic
terrorism and hate crimes that's all
that this is about and peter ducey of
course has to make it the most
melodramatic thing possible
then
peter ducey tries to make it a free
speech issue
the problem is lunatic parents at the
school board meetings then ducey tries
to make it a free speech issue does
biden support the right to protest of
course he does
so does the president support the
fundamental right of these parents to
protest at school board meetings of
course but he doesn't stand for the
fundamental right i assume you don't
either for people to take a violent
action
against members of public servants and
that's what the threats are about and so
no he doesn't stand for that right
it's one of these after another after
another
just continuing to
make something
not out of nothing
but make something
out of what you should be making the
opposite out of why are all of these
parents losing their minds going crazy
at school board meetings attacking
teachers verbally assaulting
quoting hitler as we talked about last
week on and on and on that's really the
question and uh then just one other
here's a bonus one this is a different
reporter saying why hasn't joe biden
called mitch mcconnell to try to get all
of this stuff sorted out referring to
the bills and and the the double
standard here is notable let's listen
first
why wouldn't the president given that
relationship he has with mitch mcconnell
just call mitch mcconnell and have this
conversation with him why do this
through what's the conversation about
i don't know they have the relationship
he's the one who said you could bring
the two sides together so wouldn't there
be some value in having that
conversation you know what the we know
what the risk-free option is here we
know what the clear path forward is here
uh and i think the president has made no
secret about his belief on that so
i have no problem with jo i've said it a
million times when joe biden brought
republicans to the white house and some
some people on the left from ads and
people on the right were mad great bring
them give them an opportunity to weigh
in on the covet stimulus build that was
back then they don't want to participate
let them not participate and ultimately
that's what they did
but you're not going to hold things up
it's fine to talk to them
when it was trump right
the question was
why won't democrats
give trump what he wants why are
democrats getting in the way why won't
they concede anything at all why why why
even though that was a completely
dishonest framing
now much of the corporate media has
switched to
why isn't joe biden talking to more
republicans
before
the problem was democrats weren't giving
trump what he wanted
now the problem is joe biden hasn't
called mitch mcconnell but a couple
months ago when he actually did meet
with republicans then the problem was
why is he giving republicans so much
power even though he didn't it's the
need to constantly create the most
salacious possible narrative even if it
has very little bearing on reality so
that's the press briefing let's now talk
about christmas
when a democratic president
is in power
very often fox news
talks about the war on christmas a lot
and we now have a pandemic which has
affected holidays for some time and fox
news is going absolutely crazy over very
milk toast comments that anthony fauci
made i'm going to play the clip for you
that started it all dr fauci was asked
over the weekend
are christmas gatherings good to go and
he
responding to a question said it's just
too early to say but we can gather for
christmas or it's just too soon to tell
you know margaret we it's just too soon
to tell we've just got a concentrating
on continuing to get those numbers down
and not trying to jump ahead by weeks or
months and say what we're going to do at
a particular time fauci didn't cancel
christmas he didn't even come out and
say i must talk about christmas
he was asked a question and he said it's
just kind of early fox news has now been
going for 48 hours
with the idea that fauci is canceling
christmas look at these clips here is uh
jason rantz
who is a radio host in seattle listen to
this unhinged insanity 75 or so to tell
me that it's not safe to visit your
family for christmas to say that now in
october indicates this isn't really
about public health at this point now
we're talking about taking total control
now understand what he did there this
guy's saying in october fauci is saying
no christmas no
in october found she's saying christmas
is too far away to talk about christmas
we just need to see what's happening
with the virus
another example here is
i think this is kennedy
saying why is fouchy talking about
christmas well he was asked about it he
didn't come up with the question the
problem is he's talking about christmas
and hanukkah we haven't gotten to
halloween and thanksgiving columbus
thank you dana we're getting rid of that
kids did not get to have a halloween
last year right and it's like you know
you have little kids you only have so
many of them my daughter last year had
to bake a twilight cake with little
gravestones okay yeah making drama where
there is no drama why is fouchy talking
about christmas
because he was asked by margaret brennan
about christmas that that's why
then the histrionics really get going
with tucker carlson tucker
it's it's incredible what tucker is able
to do with this the histrionic nature of
this take a look there was do not travel
for christmas anthony fauci said do not
congregate together to celebrate it that
means no christmas eve in church that
means no christmas morning under the
tree with your it's an attack on
religion like tearing through stockings
it means no christmas at all
sacred christian observance canceled
until further notice from dr anthony s
fauci md
what a thrill it must have been for him
to say something like that oh yeah
here's a guy who fully expected to spend
his life giving prostate exams and there
he was declaring the ancient christian
calendar null and void by the way is it
was uh
was fouchy heading towards urology as a
spa i don't even know what the prostate
exam thing even is so tucker blowing it
completely out of the water here's
another right-wing guy clay travis
um
saying fauci's just trying to control
holidays
new one uh but i have to say
that fauci there the constitution
matters the most in times of emergency
and crisis because that's when the
foundation of our country's documents
matter the absolute most uh imagine
dr fauci
what do you think about christmas i
don't know it's too soon to tell this
guy is attacking the constitution
and the idea that he's trying to argue
to us that we can't celebrate christmas
together and now he's saying oh i didn't
say that but you did say it he didn't
say it he didn't say it he said it's
just too soon to tell
and then lastly
here is one more of these and it's just
more pathetic than the last yes after
calling for the cancellation of
christmas again
somehow anthony fauci still has his job
never happened
just never happened and this is how the
narratives start and continue this one
has the same texture as the dr seuss who
by the way is not a medical doctor folks
you should know about that
these people are pathetic but they don't
have anything else so this is what
they're doing
remember that on tuesday october 19th we
will be doing a live viewer town hall it
will be streaming live exclusively only
on the pacman live youtube channel which
you can find at youtube.com
it won't be streaming on facebook
it won't be streaming on tick tocks
it won't be on the main youtube channel
it won't be on twitch the pacman live
channel 6 pm eastern on tuesday october
19th everybody can call in
members on our website getpriority will
be a great event
and i hope to see all of you then let's
take a quick break and we have quite a
program planned for you today one of our
sponsors is blinkist who's been
supporting the david pakman show longer
than any other sponsor blinkist is the
app that lets you listen to or read an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcast 2
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded try blinkist for free and
get 25 off a subscription go to
blinkist.com
david pakman the link is down below
welcome back to the show everybody
remember that we are primarily funded by
viewers and listeners who sign up on my
website you can find the membership sign
up form very extensive form you put in
like your email and you make a password
um at
joinpacman.com the normal membership
rates i find to be really a great deal
but what the hell do i know
um if you don't like the prices though
you can use the code better21 and get a
discount not means tested open to
everybody you decide you decide
let's hear from some people in the
audience one of the best parts of the
week for many
uh a terrible part of the week for some
others okay right let's just get into it
it's via discord you can um participate
at davidpakman.com
slash discord let's start today
with caitlin from alaska caitlyn from
alaska you were on the air
can you hear me okay i can hear you
beautifully katelyn yeah
perfect it's been a minute glad to hear
you're doing good i actually don't have
a question i just wanted to give you a
quick update here from alaska please um
since we made news with our
fantastically wonderful um
you know mass mandate discussion
um
uh oh caitlyn right as you were about to
get into the substance you glitched out
tell us again what's happening now in
alaska
i personally don't know anyone who's
passed away from covid my work is very
strict with our guidelines okay so no
one is allowed into our office without
being vaccinated
and even with that
we've had one person
catch covid
we've had two others who have been in
contact with somebody and had to
quarantine
my sister is a hairdresser and she sees
uh like a hundred people a week
and she's been lucky enough to not
catch covid right
so
it seems to me that even though alaska
is doing absolutely atrocious with
everyone i know
we're all very
we always wear our masks outside of the
house okay and so
it seems like for those of us here in
anchorage
as long as you still
continue with the mitigation efforts
along with being fully vaccinated most
people are safe
so
i the numbers are terrifying and i
really really wish we didn't have such a
ignorant mayor
but
i mean as long as people are intelligent
and use their brain we seem to be doing
okay
all right very good caitlin thank you
how many hours of uh daylight do you
have right now up there
um the sun's rising right now it's 8 12.
i would say it usually sets around six
or seven right now okay so it's starting
to become more a little more normal i
guess
normal for other people yes
very good all right caitlyn thank you
always great hearing from alaska
okay thank you caitlyn apparently
disappearing there very good well we got
our alaska update which is a great start
uh why don't we go next to john from
kentucky and see what's going on there
john what's what's happening
hi david can you hear me yes are you
calling from an airplane
uh i'm calling from a car give me one
second okay no no it's not bad it's nice
it's nice ambient noise
okay well perfect um
i was i was calling because i had a
question on a de-radicalizing leftist to
be honest okay
i i personally identify principally as a
socialist but i've recognized in my time
growing up with this particular like uh
ideology that
reality does tend to skew liberal both
from the left wing and also the right
wing
like
for example um it's frustrating when i
talk to my socialist friends who want to
pretend like there's going to be a
violent revolution of the proletariat
yeah and
it i just have to look at them like are
you guys living in the same reality as
me
or similarly with the anti-vac stuff
people taking the big pharma
to
incredibly insane conclusions i i was
just wondering if there was any way to
kind of engage with these sort of things
from a center perspective without coming
off as like a
like a shill for liberalism or sure now
just to be clear you're saying you are a
socialist but you want to talk these
peop talk to these folks more from a
centrist perspective is that what you're
saying
yeah principally i recognize that yeah i
do think it's a little bit messed up
that we have more empty houses than we
have homeless people in america for
example and that is kind of terrible
that's locked behind a privatized system
that being said in our current system
it's probably a good thing that
landlords can evict people who aren't
taking care of their investment
i see i mean listen with the in in terms
of the people who are expecting or
waiting or hoping for a violent uprising
to you know to by the proletariat i
think it makes sense to sort of talk
through
exactly how that would happen and
importantly the number of people that
might be killed or maimed in such a
revolution and see if they feel like
that the ends would justify the means
some might say yes some might say no
but i think it's good to just
have them walk you through all of the
steps if that makes sense now i've got
to ask are you driving a v8 with knobby
tires
um i'm actually just driving a good
old-fashioned 2014 ford fusion i have no
clue what kind of tires are on here wow
wow uh okay well listen uh john good
luck with the de-radicalization and
report back if you are able to
effectively do any of it
okay well thank you very much for your
time all right pleasure john from
kentucky
very strong first couple of calls not
great audio there on that second one but
we're gonna deal with it let's go next
to alex from baltimore maryland alex
you're on the air
david can you hear me i can
hey great so i have a question about
moderates in general so i feel like a
popular
take from the left is that anyone who
has a moderate even if it's a liberal
viewpoint is therefore corrupt and
therefore a shill
do you believe that to be true and how
do you tell the difference between the
two no um so you you know that thing
about like you can you know porn when
you see it
um i think people know
grifter and enlightened centrist
positions when they see them versus
someone who's just moderate i think
there's a difference between staking out
positions of neutrality to be
perceived as some kind of you know above
the fray centrist and it's often very
disingenuous and very transparent versus
there are issues on which people can
just genuinely be moderate and it
doesn't mean they've sold out to anyone
there could be you know think about
taxation there are people who might
think that the top tax rate should be 90
and some who think there should be no
taxes or a five percent flat tax and
you're gonna come come across someone
who just thinks hey like i don't know it
should be 42 percent a little bit higher
than we have now but that's it
just because they're at 42 and someone
else is at 37 and someone else is at 20
there's no particular reason to say if
you end up in the middle
you're you've it's because of a
corrupting influence there's there's no
substantive basis to believe that uh
that's different than people who just
sort of uh frame themselves as
neutral and centrist on everything to
pretend to be above bias you understand
the distinction i'm making
yeah i do again and and that's kind of
how i feel i just it's just actually my
comment was more about the commentary of
how other
progress oh yeah yeah yeah assume that
because you're a moderate yep
you are therefore you are corrupt no i
think i think that that's wrong yeah you
believe no i don't believe it either and
i guess that's my point there's no
there's no there's no substantive reason
to assume that because someone is
moderate on an issue
their view is corrupted by whatever no i
disagree with people who think that
whether they're on the left or right
fair enough and i do have a i have a
quick travel question for you because
you again i i call it a little bit a
while ago about
travel stuff um i have young kids where
would you recommend a foreign country
that is more kid-friendly oh my goodness
i have no idea what does it mean
kid-friendly i mean there's millions of
children in countries all over the world
that is true i guess my thinking on that
would be is you know things that we as
adults that to explore other countries
would be fun would not be fun for a
six-year-old right you know i guess
other places where they would have
things for kids as well and not just you
know
old cultural stuff that you and i would
find interesting but yeah a six year
eight-year-old would i have no idea what
a six or eight year old finds
interesting to be perfectly frank i i'm
so poorly positioned to answer the
question
no that's fair it was just more of a fun
question to ask you now i have one last
quickie food debate sure um it is autumn
fall whatever you prefer to call it sure
um
pumpkin spice or apple cider flavor oh
my god i don't do either but i will have
an occasional um cider donuts so i guess
i'd go cider cider flavor rather than
than pumpkin spice
uh it is a that's a fair point i
thoroughly enjoy both but i figured that
was you know you're from the northeast i
figured that'd be a big question for you
yeah yeah no the pumpkin spice stuff i'm
seeing everybody with their pumpkin
spice lattes that are half whipped cream
with it's just it should be illegal
that's my view
i don't know i i i i turn into a very
basic white girl this time of year so
all right my friend
thank you very much for the call
likewise yeah thanks very much yeah no
by the way i don't think pumpkin spice
should be illegal i just you know it's
not for me i guess is the point that i'm
trying to make
let's go next to shayna from state
college is that uh is that state college
pennsylvania
is yes
okay yeah i don't know how how is it is
it is the town called state college i
never understood it
yeah it's uh it's the um i guess the
main campus for penn penn state
university and the town is called state
college fascinating all right well
what's going on
not much a pleasure to speak with you
really enjoy the show i have a quick
question would you ever uh consider
doing a long form discussion with uh
jordan peterson i know you and he have a
lot of uh disagreements i think it'd be
fascinating to hear you two go back and
forth for a couple hours sure he's been
on before and he's welcome back any time
okay
i didn't i think that'd be i think a lot
of people would benefit from uh
from seeing that yeah i mean he may be
too big for the david pakman show now i
don't know that he would do it quite
frankly
oh is that right yeah i mean i don't
know i don't think there's a guarantee
that peterson needs needs or wants to
appear on my show right now
and i guess the other question with that
is um
what what are your current thoughts on
the uh idw and what do you say about um
because i've read different forums and
things and some people have uh placed
you
um in that crowd what do you think of
them and what's going on oh yeah i i
don't know anything about that um but
i honestly haven't thought of
thought about or seen anything about the
intellectual dark web for
i would say a year or longer i don't
know
i don't know if it still quote exists
i just have no idea whatsoever i mean do
they are they still have they disbanded
was it ever really banded um i just have
no idea it seems correct me if i'm wrong
but it seems as though the relevance and
number of mentions have declined
dramatically
that's what i've noticed as well and i
didn't even
think it was a formal group i thought it
was just sort of like a loose collection
of
similar kind of
thinkers and
and whatnot now i know um and i haven't
heard you
talk about uh
this guy very much but uh i don't know
if you've been following brett weinstein
and the dark horse podcast and some of
the things that they've been saying over
there yeah no i have i'm aware of the
you know
spike protein is cytotoxic phase and the
ivermectin is fantastic phase and
all of these different i i am aware of
what's going on but i've i've taken
mostly
a sam harris approach where
it's very hard to really
like go point counterpoint because they
kind of put out a fire hose of stuff and
if they mention one thing you're not
prepared for or can immediately refute
it comes off as though they're really
making good points and so you know for
similar reasons as sam harris has stated
i'm not like super directly engaging
with it
that that kind of corresponds with my
take on it as as well because i i did
actually follow the um
the podcast he and his uh wife did uh
for a while but then as time wore on i
just found that i wasn't resonating
uh with what they were
saying quite as much and i had to do a
lot more kind of digging to really
kind of see if what they were saying
squared with
you know what the vast majority of other
experts were saying and eventually i
just decided that they weren't for me
yeah that's fair that's completely fair
everybody should make informed decisions
about media consumption i'm glad you did
absolutely well i think that that's it
for me but real of the show support what
you're doing thank you very much my
pleasure thank you so much for the call
we're going to take just a very brief
break but we're going to continue the
calls so if you're holding on to talk to
me
unless you're furious at how long you've
been holding and are about to hang up in
a rage
just hold on another moment and we're
going to go right back to the discord
lines in a second
all right let's hear from a few more
people today we are now taking calls via
discord it typically works really really
well you can find the discord at
davidpakman.com
discord let's go across the pond i hope
i'm pronouncing this correctly is it
chinese in the united kingdom
hi yes it's shanice can you hear me i
can hear you fine are you calling in
from nottingham
i am yes yes what a pleasure in the uk
what a
pleasure um thanks i'm a huge fan of the
show um my question was i was just
wondering um why do you think that the
left
kind of uh branding and messaging is
generally so much less successful than
the right i feel as though whenever um
you know the left come up with something
like defund the police or something like
that um it just kind of tends to cause
like a lot of infighting uh it doesn't
really tend to kind of like go as well
whereas when the right come up with
something it always tends to kind of
work a little bit better do you think
it's just kind of i feel as if it's
almost like the bully in the playground
like the wright's voice is just louder
they kind of just go along with points
without really any kind of evidence but
it tends to work better for them than it
does kind of for us on the left
beautiful question so i think that
there's two answers depending on the
circumstances so sometimes the left just
comes up just brands a bad idea okay so
like defund the police wasn't a good
idea it was a bad idea and as i
explained in my ten point police reform
plan
uh reallocation of resources yes reform
replacing police with social workers for
some types of calls yes but in some
places you might need to increase
funding for police in order to
accomplish those things or to be at the
proper level of staffing in order to
have police uh be
uh more proactive than reactive okay so
like defund the police was a bad idea be
as a slogan because the idea itself is
not a good idea that's one side but
there's a whole other set of examples
which are sometimes
the left assumes that because we have
the right idea
that the branding doesn't matter and we
just have to explain the idea and
everybody will like it and the right who
has the wrong idea is like that doesn't
really matter we just need a slogan and
they come up with a slogan and it works
i mean a pro-life is a great example and
so is tax relief pro-life well actually
what you're doing is you're picking and
choosing certain medical situations that
should be left to patients and doctors
and assigning a name to it where if
you're against it it's like wow that
your anti-life if you're not pro-life
you're anti-life by definition that's
really good branding even though the
policy makes no sense tax relief
anytime taxes go down it's the relief of
a burden so even though the real
situation with taxes is you need
well-balanced taxes and well allocated
in order to pay for the things that we
all expect would be paid for through
taxation tax relief listen we're
relieving people of this burden so
sometimes the left is completely correct
on the position and they assume that the
facts alone will win people over and the
right's like no we can just come up with
a better slogan so two different
categories there shanice
that makes perfect sense i really agree
with what you're saying i also think i
liked what you were saying the other day
as well about um
these kind of uh
politicians who seem to kind of be doing
everything with the coronavirus like
wrong and incorrectly they could kind of
be called like pro-vaccine i think
things like that is like a really good
idea pro-virus you mean pro-virus yeah
pro-virus sorry
yeah yeah no definitely i mean let's
call them what they are they seem to be
on the side of the virus and especially
when okay they might refuse the vaccine
but you're also going to refuse getting
tested like what's the reason that that
doesn't make any sense so yeah these are
all uh relevant examples
okay thank you so much for answering my
questions my pleasure i appreciate the
call
all right shanice from nottingham
uk
uh great great call why don't we go
next
to
you know we tried last time and it
didn't work let's go to eric from cancun
mexico eric are you with us this time
david hello yes
i'm great pleasure to talk to you i've
been trying for months and weeks
here's the thing i'm thinking um
my family wants to get a passport to us
and i'd like to visit the states but
i've been seeing your videos and from
parent cousins and young turks and i've
seen very deranged individuals both
civilians and the police and army
the thing is
we easy for tourists and foreigners to
go there with all the wackos and
psychopaths around
i mean listen everybody needs to do
their own risk assessment but
statistically speaking statistically
speaking
the us is not an unsafe place to be you
know there are safer and less safe
places in the us the big country
in the big cities you have to take the
normal precautions that you take in any
big city
um but you need to make that assessment
i mean the u.s is not an unsafe place to
go to statistically but that doesn't
mean bad things don't happen bad things
happen all the time you really have to
make that call
yeah i'm
i'm really with the mindset that i like
in the song of alpha bill of forever
young hoping for the best but expect the
worst like what happened in that mode in
el paso
and other thing i've been a martial
artist since 8 years old would it be
illegal for me to defend myself or would
i be charged with assault if i fight
back
uh i think you would be perfectly within
your legal rights to defend yourself
regardless of your martial arts training
yeah i've been in taekwondo in krav maga
in capoeira a bit of jujitsu and karate
yeah
is it a pleasure
and one quick thing
do you remember when republicans were
mad at dr seuss
yes and you know he's not even a real
doctor he's not a medical doctor
um i think they would be angry because
they made
books about trump's other relatives for
example he is left-leaning uncle dolores
he is
more naughty but logical's half-sister
the sour kangaroo and he is more
handsome and more wholesome causing the
grinch
you think very nice very nice eric i i
love it um how how is cancun which part
of cancun do you live in the downtown or
where
and in the heart of downtown
it's very nice it's
it's like um sauna old year but in
winter
it's climatizing
beautiful all right
eric thank you so much for the call we
love our mexican viewers
thank you all right there is eric
eric from cancun what a call folks what
a call maybe my new favorite caller i
have to tell you
let's go next to
how about enrique from north carolina
you're on the air
hi david yes
it's outside and talking to you
please
so my question is do you know anything
about daca
futures lining up for that
no
i mean it's
i've been saying for a very long time
that there we need a permanent solution
when it comes to daca it just we just
need it it has to happen but um i am not
aware
i wish i could tell you i think it's
coming soon i don't really think it's
coming soon i don't not this year anyway
yeah are you you're you're a daca
recipient
uh yeah i was brought in here when i was
one year old
sorry you were born here or brought here
at one year old i missed that
oh i was
brought right here at one year old that
makes sense yeah most people are born at
zero not at one i figured i misheard
oh yeah
and how old are you now
uh i'm 21 now wow so this is this is
really your country
oh yeah i mean i know more
i'm more american than i am that's
right i love i love you know mexican
culture but
i i grew up in american culture you know
i speak english i'm just as american as
anyone else here for sure
yeah i mean if if if someone came to you
and said sir you've got to go back to
mexico
i can only imagine how devastating that
would be
i'll all be freaking out i don't know
what i would do yeah
yeah well listen
i'm with you we need a solution i hope
that that we get to it sooner than later
but
realistically it doesn't seem like
there's a political appetite to get it
done this this year at minimum
now
all right thank you david
my pleasure thank you so much for
calling in
yeah i mean uh you know millions of
people in that situation millions
millions
um
is it millions maybe it's not now i
misremember is it hundreds of thousands
many people many people
let's go next to
josie from michigan josie you're on the
air
what's up david how are you doing how
you doing
good i just wanted to know um what do
you think about the 30 u.s school
children still stuck in afghanistan
right now
i'm not aware of the number of people
left what are the circumstances were
they on like a some kind of summer trip
or something believe it or not um they
were on a school trip i don't know who
takes their
school children to afghanistan that's my
question i mean it's it's
now i know that sometimes when people
say
how on earth would you take kids people
come back and say there's much to learn
culturally historically i i don't deny
that i don't deny that i just don't
understand
given the security situation who who
would do that what age kids are they are
they high schoolers do you know
uh i think i heard something along the
lines of one of the principal or one of
the students dad is a us official or
something like that and they were going
now have they do we know i don't know
anything about the story have joe
biden's administration has said anyone
who wants to get out we will help get
out there's no time limit on it like are
they are is there is this in the middle
of a process or what's going on yeah
it's really hard to find information on
at this point because even if you google
it at this point it only shows articles
up till like september 3rd and then
there's been no word on it since it's
been mentioned really is it possible
they got out but there just haven't been
articles written because there's less of
a story once they're just back in the us
that's possible i don't know i just
thought it would be it was worthy you
would think you would think
i mean listen like i've said before
we've got to support everybody who wants
to get out joe biden said there's no
time limit if you don't want to get out
now and then in a month you do he says
the u.s will help and do everything that
the government can so let's hope they
stick to it
yeah let's hope all right good talking
to you david my pleasure thanks for the
call there's josie from michigan
um a lot of a lot of good questions
today let's try a different country just
for kicks how about fiona from germany
fiona you're on the air
hello
i will
thought about the afghanistan topic
again and we have data on how much
civilian support staff has been working
with the military
but
the data has been collected by civilian
organizations and only made available to
government or listened to by the
government
as recently as like the 10th of
september and i would like to know the
american situation do you think that
would be listened to if a civilian
organization would like mention civilian
support staff that may or may not be
interested in leaving afghanistan and if
so would there be assistance rendered
i i apologize i'm not sure i understand
the question you're saying
american civilian support staff
currently in afghanistan is that who
we're talking about no uh civilian
afghan support staff that happen to
support european troops
is also being evacuated in a very very
small situation and chair
uh are are you listening to some video
in the background i just heard someone
say hi how are you
no oh that was weird
um
i don't know i mean i don't know if they
would qualify for asylum or refugee
status i'm just not sure
uh
it's very hard for me to answer that
question i i just don't know yeah it's a
convoluted thing yeah it's just popped
in my mind but thank you for calling on
me oh no problem how are things in
germany are okay
they have been very good yeah excellent
i spent 24 hours there last month and it
was fantastic
well
that's nice to hear yeah i hope to be
back any of the political campaigning
in germany no i have not no idea
it was very startling to be when it
appeared and it was so tiny and small
you didn't see that other countries yeah
no i that's for sure all right thank you
so much for the call
goodbye okay very good uh let's hear
from a couple of other people
why don't we go to
uh nathan from california nathan you're
on the air
hey david um
i work in the wedding industry and a
uh recently a local politician has
gotten some flack on the news for
attending a a private event and um
i just wanted to know what your thoughts
on kind of like the hypocrisy of uh
politicians saying that you should wear
a mask indoors
while
they're attending these private events
yeah i mean listen there's obvious
hypocrisy there's no question about it
um also
sometimes public health guidelines
are supported
at a governmental level and individuals
assess their own risk and they do
different things i mean okay you know it
doesn't make it not hypocritical it just
is something that happens um
i don't know about the event you know
sometimes people go to i've gone to a
couple of events where
everybody's got to be vaccinated and
gets a test on the way in and then like
i went to a dinner with 10 people like
that last month and that
seemed quite reasonable and and we don't
know what the testing requirement is i'm
about to go to a wedding where
everybody's going to be tested uh so i
don't know i mean of course there's some
level of hypocrisy and then at the same
time i think a lot of the stuff is in
the details
okay i mean uh do you think like at a
certain point like personal
responsibility will be kind of like the
like ultimately like the thing that
people will have to like take upon
themselves outside of like these mass
mandates yeah i mean i think it's going
to go more and more in that direction
and like dr isaac bogash last week told
us once we really have a high enough
level of vaccination and hopefully the
virus becomes less serious where
the the death risk goes down even more
then it becomes more about each
individual making the decision for
themselves we're not at that point right
now for a number of different reasons
the virus is still far more serious than
the flu and not not nearly enough people
are vaccinated so yes it's going to go
more and more towards just personal
decisions but we're nowhere near that
yet
awesome well thank you for taking my
call my pleasure very good question
appreciate it all right thanks everybody
who called in that's going to do it for
today we'll take calls again and i'll
speak to more people uh we'll take a
quick break and be right back
all right let's get into this week's
mailbag i got a weird email from someone
last week saying i should call this my
apple bag which is just strange i think
it relates to that weird nicki minaj
story and i talked about apple bags but
i don't think apple bags is an
appropriate name for this segment this
is the mailbag
you can participate maybe if your email
is interesting and smart enough or crazy
enough right there's two types
by emailing info
davidpakman.com this has been uh an
increasingly popular segment emails are
just dumping in people wanting their
questions answered uh let's just get
right into it folks please
starting with brian brian wrote i don't
even care that brian spelled my name
wrong he says mr pakman
i enjoy your show i have heard you
comment a few times about donald trump
misstating the 1918 spanish flu by
repeating 1917 spanish flu he is not
getting this wrong on accident 17 is a
kewanon reference or canine as some say
or shout out every time he uses 17
incorrectly it is done purposefully
thank you for what you do yeah we had a
caller last week on live calls who said
the same thing which is q is the 17th
letter of the alphabet right i'm so m is
13
n
14
o 15
p 16 q 17. that that part checks out
maybe that's true i've now heard this
from a few people
maybe yeah i don't know and if that's
the case it would be
really
disturbing about what it says about
former president trump that he is sort
of surreptitiously signaling to the q
anon conspiracy theorist i would put
nothing past trump whatsoever part of me
wonders whether he's clever or smart
enough to even do that maybe somebody
gave him the idea i think the most
likely explanation is also the simplest
one trump misstated the 1918 flu as the
1917 flu once
uh nobody corrected him or they did but
trump is too much of a narcissist to
change it because it would concede that
he said something wrong so he's just
continuing to call it the 1917 flu that
that's my uh sort of guess
next email is from wayno wayno says sir
how does youtube's ban on misinformation
affect joe rogan
it's a good question i think you're
referring to youtube banning all
anti-vac stuff it's pretty clear to me
that joe rogan is staying
on this side of the youtube rules
um
some of his guests may be on their own
channels are going past that line
but my instinct in looking at the
updated rules and remember that the
updated rules from youtube about they've
banned anti-vaxxers and anti-vaxx
content um
it
the it was already in place for covid
vaccine stuff they've just expanded it
to be all anti-vac stuff and so since
the controversial subject matter on
rogan's channel has been about when it
comes to vaccines the covet vaccine
that ban was already in place so i don't
actually think that the new rules will
really affect rogan a lot of people may
not know this but there's much more
content demonetized on youtube um then
there is removed there's actually i mean
of course like straight up gore and
violence and out and out
conspiracy anti-vaxx stuff it's removed
the vast majority of content is just
demonetized when it violates terms and
conditions so my belief is
joe rogan is not going to be affected by
this in any way
next email today is from daniel
daniel says evidence the pentagon
has gave way more money
to the wuhan lab
than dr fauci's nih
and the fact that peter dazzak
is the main one who gave all that money
to the wuhan scientists directly
and how one seems to care
i think what daniel is trying to say
is that despite what he believes to be
evidence about money going from the nih
to the wuhan lab
that no one seems to care i i believe
that that's what this email is about
um
listen i've weighed in on this before
my view is
i want to know the truth about the world
period
i am not this is not a show where
either for posturing
or
for narrative crafting or for any reason
i exclude things from the show that i
believe are important
or lie to the audience in any way i
always give my opinion i want to know
the truth about the wuhan lab and
funding and dr fauci and the entire
thing
um i think what's important is that we
understand first of all how much of this
entire dr fauci controversy
fundamentally comes down to semantics
which i talked about last week on the
friday show with a caller who called in
that's number one and number two
um there is a lot of misinformation
about this issue so i continue
to
look when things come across my desk or
my screen as it might better be said
into the nih wuhan issue
and if i have some kind of major thing
to come to you with and say sirs and
mams
here's some news uh you can rest assured
that i will do that let's go to the next
email
this is very weaponized now i should
actually even take it off the screen for
a second
if there are kids in the room get them
out
if you have dogs that are particularly
sensitive to cringe get them out cats
they don't give a damn what the hell is
on the screen
uh but in all seriousness this this is
very very weaponized william wrote to me
and said they all died
david
i am the only member of my family and
friend group
who was smart enough
to not listen to celebrity propaganda
and unfortunately i was right
almost everyone i know personally has
died from a vaccine
my mother and i are the only ones left
she took the vaccine but thankfully
her immune system kicked it out that's
actually it's so it's so crazy it's
funny
what am i supposed to do now that
everybody i know and love is dead
because of your stupid vaccine
um
does this even deserve a reply
like i don't even i'm not even you know
um
this is either someone i mean like what
what is this right okay so it could be
just someone who's trolling fine let's
imagine it's not
this could be someone who's family
really has tragically died
from different issues could be even
covered and they are wrongly blaming it
on being vaccinated also they say from a
vaccine not necessarily even cohen so it
could be someone who is misattributing
death to vaccines
could be someone who's completely
delusional and disconnected from the
real world um
i don't know could could be a serial
murderer who's killed people into saying
it was vaccine this could be anything
other than what it purports to be i
think that that's sort of where i would
leave it uh but these folks are out
there
anthony wrote to me and said
misleading characterization mr pakman it
is often stated in the media that most
republicans believe trump won the 2020
election wouldn't it be more accurate to
say that most republicans
claim they believe trump won the
election big difference no
this is a beautiful question
we talked about this before
um and we talked about this in a segment
where i talked about
the kind of magical thinking and we're
at war mentality of many of these trump
supporters
where we wondered
when they say we believe trump won
do they really believe it or is it the
way they are choosing to answer polls in
order to be part of the right team and
in order to perpetuate some more general
idea that they don't like joe biden they
don't like that joe biden won
and i think that uh i i know i've been
citing this a lot lately
but neil postman in technopoly has a
very good couple pages about exactly
this issue about opinion polling which
is
opinion polling
we opinion polling becomes an invisible
technology in the sense that we just
look at the results of the poll and we
don't think about why was it done who
did it what does it really mean to
answer questions in one way or the other
and how were the questions asked
and what a poll tells us is
an opinion poll tells us what people
claim to believe
and people might claim to believe
something they don't believe for
different reasons we talked you know
there was this idea that the the polls
leading into 2020 that said joe biden
was winning were wrong
because the wrong people were being
pulled right sampling problem or there
were people
uh bashful trump supporters not willing
to say that they supported trump but
they really did it it ended up basically
being false i mean wisconsin was off
there's no doubt about it but it
basically was was not true
but when it comes to what people believe
about the 2020 election it's important
to say that the polls tell us what
people claim to believe and they may not
actually believe the things they claim
to believe for a whole bunch of
different reasons very good point a next
email is from larry larry says keep
drinking now it gets crazy
now by the way keep drinking the
kool-aid biden is the worst president in
my lifetime a liar a wife stealer and he
has been selling out our country for his
family's benefit for decades
it sounds like larry's describing trump
quite frankly larry goes on to say
trader joe's where everything is for
sale
big far here we go with this stuff big
pharma must also love you they are also
a criminal organization and have you
convinced hook line and sinker that they
are our savior open your eyes young man
so
the first part is just whacked i mean
like hard whacked
um
the the last part you know a bunch of
people have written in and they've said
david clearly you're being paid to
promote vaccines and i tweeted about
this earlier in the week
why would anyone pay me to promote like
first of all promote
i report on the science of vaccines
um but
why would anyone pay me to promote
vaccines were it were small potatoes
right like in the grand scheme of things
it would be sort of a dumb thing to do
and in addition why would they pay me
given that i've reported on the science
of vaccines for a long time like they
don't
what else can i really say about
vaccines other than reporting when they
work and uh what the impact of those
vaccinations is and this is part of the
sort of superstructure around
vaccination disinformation that's out
there which is that some of the people
there's lies being told it's all lies is
the point um there's lies being told
about how safe the vaccine is that's the
people who email in and they say
thousands
tens of thousands hundreds of thousands
of people died from the vaccine that's
one part
but then also the people telling you
what they claim is the science of
vaccines
those people have been paid
so they simply can't be believed it
looks like they're giving you science
but they're giving you stuff they've
been given by someone that paid them
and the whole point of it is not to just
accept reality and live in in this other
world which is preferable to them
it's a preferable world to them it's
simpler and that's the appeal of some
conspiracy theories a lot of people
find it
hard to accept
that
bad things happen unpredictable things
happen every 100 years or so we get a
100 year pandemic
but we've got a vaccine that helps
that sounds out of control to a lot of
people it's more appealing to believe
this was all just done by humans um
that's where you get the vaccine i'm
sorry the virus was created in a
bioweapons lab and released because
that's control it's not a random event
it's not a probabilistic event anymore
and the vaccine is also part of the
exact same plot it's all a plot for some
people
even though they claim to be outraged by
it they would rather live in a world
where everything is controlled by man
rather than than things that can happen
that are left to chance unpredictable
bad things that's at the root of much
conspiracism okay last one today here's
a bonus
um this one came in via facebook on
monday morning this is from george this
is really wild george says
you keep calling trump supporters
delusional
i truly hope that you open your eyes
before the communist
democrat nazi party come for you a few
contradictions there
trump did not lose the 2020 election
it was part of a colors revolution
colors
revolution educate yourself educate your
followers and open your eyes otherwise
you might just find yours you might find
yourself on that train
just like the jews found themselves on a
nazi train
except this time it won't be gas
it'll be an injection
they call it a vaccine dumbass
folks
folks
this is what we're up against we're
gonna have to try to solve the problems
of humanity
despite people like this i don't see any
way to get them to help us maybe we can
prevent them from hurting us maybe
but it is not looking very good not
looking very good get your emails in for
next week's mailbag info
davidpakman.com
we have a fantastic bonus show today
it's all me today on the bonus show i
know many people expecting only producer
pat today it's all me i will see you on
the bonus trip
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 percent
off a subscription by going to
blinkist.com
david pakman